hi there i'm peter
this is joint work with pavon and vinod
we're going to be presenting our
complete problems for
multi-pseudo-deterministic computation
so what we have is some natural problems
that are in a sense complete
for pseudo-deterministic computations
what we mean is if these problems
have pseudo-deterministic algorithms
then
lots of other problems also have
pseudo-deterministic algorithms
so first i'm going to explain what
exactly pseudo-determinism is
and then a generalization called
multi-pseudo-determinism
and then explain what exactly our
completeness result
says and how we get
so we're going to be focused on search
problems
and function problems so
we've got problems with multiple correct
outputs you want to
compute one of them
so we're going to use sx to denote the
set of acceptable outputs
for a particular input x so like an
example
we want to generate prime numbers so you
get
a one to the n as an input and you gotta
generate
an n bit prime if
like let's say n is four then s
x would be 11 and 13
because those are the four bit prime
numbers or
you want to find non-roots of some
big polynomial
there s x would be the set of all things
that aren't roots that polynomial
and so both of these problems there's
fast random algorithms where you
basically pick something at random and
then
test to see if it's a in
sx the downside is
each time you run it you might find a
different element of sx and sometimes
that
isn't what you want um like you know
that algorithm for here n equals 4
half the time you'll get 11 half the
time you'll get 13.
so like
let's say you're in a distributed
computing setting you know you might
want uh
every process to agree on a particular
prime number
and so this motivated the following
definition
uh we say an algorithm is
pseudo-deterministic
if for each input there is
a like canonical output
that we find with at least two-thirds
probability
this is just like a simple diagram where
like
imagine these are the different random
strings and then the
blue letters are the uh elements of sx
the
acceptable outputs this this one isn't
pseudo deterministic
uh it's still a fine algorithm for the
problem because you get
a good answer three-fourths of the time
but what we're looking for is a
pseudo-deterministic algorithm that
will always output the same thing
so
one other reason that pseudo-determinism
is kind of neat is
suppose p equals bpp that is like we can
de-randomize
every um bpp computation
uh make it fully deterministic um
that doesn't immediately derandomize
search bpp there can be random function
computations that
don't um get derandomized for free by
this
as far as we know it's not known either
way
but um derandomizing bpp is
equivalent to making all
pseudo-deterministic algorithms
deterministic
and one thing i should mention is that
decision
problems are kind of trivially
pseudo-deterministic
so pseudo-determinism kind of connects
search to decision problems in this way
uh so here's some of the prior work
on pseudorandomness the paper that
defined it uh gave a couple of neat
pseudo deterministic algorithms um
gannon goldwasser showed that uh you can
do
you can find generators for some cyclic
groups
you can find non-residues
and non-roots of polynomials
suited deterministically
goldwasser and grossman showed that you
can
pseudo deterministically construct a
bipartite perfect matching in randomized
nc
um
you can if you could pseudo
deterministically
estimate the size of an np language
um in bpp with an np
oracle then we'd get some new circuit
lower bounds that's how we
sort of got into pseudo-determinism
um it's possible to
generate prime pseudo-deterministically
in sub-exponential time at infinitely
many input lengths
that was shown by oliveira and synthonym
[Music]
and then goldwasser grossman holden
considered pseudo-determinism for
interactive proofs and
goldwasser grossman mohanty and woodruff
considered
pseudo-determinism for streaming
algorithms
so there's a lot of way uh
places and ways you can apply this
concept
all right so now it's time for our
results
so we're going to start by discussing
pseudo-determinism for approximation
algorithms
um so an approximation algorithm
we've got a function if it outputs an
integer we want to compute
f of x but sometimes that's hard
so we'll settle for getting close to f
of x
uh there's two different ways you can
measure this you can
consider a multiplicative approximation
that means that you're
off by some factor that's based on this
epsilon
or an additive approximation where
you're like within plus or minus
epsilon um
and what we'd like is to get
pseudo-deterministic approximation
algorithms
and it's easy to get
really close um
you can make every approximation
algorithm
you can narrow it down to one of two
values
and the way you do this is you pick
some thresholds to round to so we'll
if it's from here to here we round up to
the blue line if it's here to here we
round up to this blue line
and if it's here to here we round up to
here
um so
we pick this the size of the intervals
so that um our approximation error
um can't contain
more than two blue lines uh
and that means that you know wherever f
of x is
um
it'll either get rounded to one line or
the next line
but you can't have something that gets
rounded to this line something that gets
rounded to this line something gets
rounded to here
no matter where f of x happens to be
so that motivated
uh goldrick to define
determinism where instead of a canonical
solution we have a canonical
set of size k
and we land in the canonical set
with uh probability k plus one over k
plus two um and this this is kind of a
natural analog of the
two over three for pseudo-determinism
and it's actually very important to have
this because
we don't know how to amplify this
probability
if it starts out below here
if it's at least k plus one over k plus
two we can um
you know do standard amplification
techniques we run it a lot of times and
output the most common value but if you
drop below this probability
that there could be a bad output that's
more likely than any individual good
input
and this is actually also closely
connected to some
earlier work by grossmann and liu
they considered this idea of
reproducible algorithm
where you have a two-part algorithm the
first part
um uses randomness to generate a string
and like a k-bit string
and the second part
kind of behaves pseudo-deterministically
once you give it the k-bit string
and then in the multi-pseudo-determinism
paper goldreich showed that um
these are equivalent like
order k reproducible is equivalent to
two to the order k
pseudo-deterministic which makes sense
because
if you've got you could have like two to
the k different strings and then that
kind of
fixes what your canonical set is
all right so our completeness result
the complete problem we consider is
estimating the
collision probability uh
this is an approximation problem so it's
too pseudo deterministic
um and we so we've got a circuit with a
one bit output we want to estimate
the chance of getting zero twice
or getting one twice on a random input
and we proved that this is complete
for approximation algorithms um
in the sense of like the suited
context of pseudo-determinism in the
sense that
if you can make this
pseudo-deterministic you can make any
approximation algorithms to
deterministic
um so we start with an approximation
algorithm we make it
two so deterministic and now
we've got two things that we might get
we could get a or b
and we want to get rid of one of them we
know that
the chance of getting a or b
is combined at least three over four but
we don't know
how likely a is versus b
so one way we could try to get rid of
one of them
is we uh run a lot of times and we
take whichever one occurs more often
if there's a gap in the probabilities of
getting like if a is
more likely than b uh by some you know
some decent
gap then this will work very well
but if a and b are very close in
probability
this won't be pseudo deterministic at
all
uh on the other hand we could try to
run a until we know both good outputs
and then pick you know use some
arbitrary tie break rule like we'll take
the larger of the two
but this one isn't going to be
pseudo-deterministic if
we have a low chance of seeing
one of the values um
so like if you think about it like as we
run
like let's say b has a let's say we run
a
20 times b and that just happens to be
where we have a 50 chance of getting b
after running a 20 times um
and then that gives us you know we'll
output a unless we see
b um and then it's not super
deterministic we've got a 50 50 chance
of outputting a or b
so what we want to do is combine the two
strategies
and use our uh collision probability
estimator
to pseudo deterministically choose
between them
and this works because if a and b have
very close probabilities
it's kind of more uniform so we get a
lower collision probability
and if one of them is really rare then
we're going to collide on
b a lot
uh so estimating the collision
probability
that's how we like decide between the
two
and we need we need the pseudo
determinism on the estimation because
otherwise we might
get an input where we pick strategy one
half the time in strategy two the other
half
all right so here's a little depiction
of the algorithm
oh let's just assume a is the less
likely one so it's got probability
between zero and one half
and let's say up to here a
is too small to see reliability reliably
so the second strategy is bad
up here a is too close to b so strategy
one is bad and then in this big middle
section
both are perfectly fine
but we aren't we can't measure
probability of a directly
we measure the collision probability so
there's some uncertainty when we do that
like
if the so what we want to say is that if
the collision probability is
up to here then um
the probability of a is at most here
so up to here could be bad
and up to here
could be bad for strategy one
and then we set our threshold right here
and we need our estimation error to be
small enough
that if we're to the right of the
threshold
we can't possibly land in
the red zone and if we're to the left of
the threshold we can't possibly land in
the yellow zone
and that means that if we're to the
right of our threshold
then strategy two is perfectly safe
and for to the left then strategy one is
so here's that idea written out as a
algorithm
the you build the circuit that
simulates a of x you estimate the
collision probability
of c of x um
and the threshold we pick is
34 over 64. there's a lot of flexibility
though
uh you can fit you can play around with
the constants quite a bit
um and here's our strategy one strategy
two
and the here's the numbers on
why this works so
let's say we're in the
bad case on the right where the two have
very close probabilities
so if they're at mo like
if they're within two epsilon of each
other then
both of them have to be below one half
plus
epsilon and then the collision
probability is bounded by
the chance of getting a twice
plus the chance of getting b twice which
is like it works out to
one half plus two epsilon squared
on the other hand if one of them is like
if a is occurs less than epsilon of the
time
then the chance of getting b has to be
at least this
because a plus b is at least
three-fourths of the time
so that that gives us a collision
probability lower bound of
9 16.
and then if our estimate is tight enough
and
this um error we pick here
is tight enough we'll always choose a
good strategy and we can kind of
we we just decide on what epsilon we
want to deal with beforehand and that
affects how many times we have to run
a so if
like in this case we need to run a like
you know maybe
two epsilon times to have a good enough
chance of seeing
a and we can pick
you know we can run it a lot if we want
a really good chance and so yeah
and then it's easy to see that the whole
thing will be pseudo deterministic
because
um everything after picking the strategy
happens with very high probability and
we pick the strategy suited
deterministically
so that's not the only complete problem
we get
we also show that estimating the entropy
of a circuit
shannon entropy and estimating the
probability of getting one from a
circuit are also complete
because if you can do either these
pseudo deterministically you can do
collision probability estimation
so we want to consider this
like push this beyond just approximation
algorithms
so we're going to talk about
multi-valued functions
that's just a very general concept where
f x is
an arbitrary set um
and about search bpp here we've got
a relation r
and we can
so we need a probabilistic algorithm
that
outputs you know like kind of finds
solutions to the relation uh
two-thirds at least two-thirds of the
time and
the key difference is we also need to be
able to
check that a pair is in the relation
um with like two-thirds success rate
that is like the relation is kind of a
bpp decision problem
so first for multi-value functions
uh we showed that
if there's a pseudo-deterministic
algorithm to estimate collision
probability
um with small enough error then
any multi-valued function with a
constant pseudo-deterministic algorithm
can be made fully pseudo deterministic
so collision probability estimation is
complete for
constant pseudo-determinism multi-valued
functions
and we kind of take the algorithm for
the approximation algorithm case
and we modify it to work
for like a generic
k to k plus one you basically just have
to change the constants around
um make some of them smaller run it like
k times as much and
each time you go from k to k
minus one uh it
increases the run time by like
you you take the runtime to like a the
power of four
times some other constant
um so the runtime grows really fast but
as long as you only do it a constant
number of times it's still
polynomial time
for search bpp the result we have is
that
if you if there's a pseudo-deterministic
approximation scheme
for acceptance probability
then you can make any search bpp
algorithm fully suited deterministic
this isn't a completeness result in the
same sense because
um we don't have
a verification procedure for acceptance
probability so
it's not a search bpp problem
um
but how we do this is
prefix search um
[Music]
so for input x
two thirds of the random strings have to
be good
uh so by conditional probabilities you
know
either two-thirds of random strings
starting with zero are good
or two-thirds of the random strings
starting with one are good
so first we'll check um with zero
so we fix the first bit we estimate this
probability
if it's at least like if at least
two-thirds minus
epsilon are good
we'll keep the first bit being zero
otherwise we'll keep the first bit being
one
and epsilon is the error on our
acceptance probability estimator
so after so we move on to the next bit
and
we're going to lose epsilon each time we
do this
because if
but we kind of underestimate the
probability you know we
we have to take one of these and so the
best we can do is
um shrink it by epsilon
every time we uh fix a bit
so that gives us this constraint that um
the length of the random string times
epsilon
has to be less than two-thirds
but as long as we end up with a positive
value at the end
the string has to produce a good output
if our estimator gives us a
pseudo-deterministic
like gives us the canonical solution
every time we run it
then the algorithm's behavior is
basically deterministic
i mean we get our estimate
we all we do is we look at it and decide
which value to keep
so the probability of getting
the canonical random string out of this
is the chance of our acceptance
probability estimator giving the
canonical solution
every time we run it and since we can
just amplify that probability as big as
needed
so where can we go from here um
one thing is what other problems are
complete
can we get completeness in other
settings um
like people have considered pseudo
determinism for streaming can you make a
completeness notion in
that sense um
can we get a complete problem that's
actually in search bpp
and this is actually uh discussed in
this paper by gold wright goldwater and
ron
um where they gave a semi-complete
problem
that was not also not in search bpp um
and last uh
are there search problems that don't
have pseudo-deterministic algorithms
can you get that if i assume like could
you prove that if you assume p is not
equal to bpp
because obviously if p is equal to pp
then
uh yeah
all right that's everything thank you
for listening